hey
is
nope
this
so
ready
thank you
okay
oh
i
thank you
the terrible
as laid out in the speaker's announce
policies
of january 4th 2021
in accordance with the guidance and
advice
of the attending physician members
advise
to remain in the chamber only if they
are participating in debate
and must wear a mask at all times even
when
under recognition for debate
members must also practice proper social
distancing when present in the chamber
let the records show that there is a
gross violation
of this guidance from this attendance on
the republican side of the aisle
please in the interest of your own
health
and as an example to the american people
abide by the numbers now up to 25
on each side of the aisle to participate
in this stage of the development okay
pursuant to senate concurrent resolution
one
pursuing to senate concurrent resolution
one and section
17 of title three congress of the us
united states code when the two houses
withdraw
from the joint session to count the
electoral vote
for separate consideration of an
objection a representative may speak to
the
objection for five minutes and not more
than once
debate shall not exceed two hours after
which the sheriff will put in
the question shall the objection be
agreed to
the clerk will report the objection made
in the joint session
objection to counting the electoral
votes of the state of arizona
we a member of the house of
representatives and a united states
senator
object to the counting of the electoral
votes of the state of arizona on the
ground that they were
that they were not under all of the
known circumstances regularly given
signed paul gosar representative state
of arizona
ted cruz senator state of texas
thank you the chair will endeavor to
alternate
recognition between members seeking
support of the objection
and members seeking opposition to the
objection
the chair represents recognizes the
gentleman from louisiana mr scalise
for five minutes thank you madam speaker
i rise today to object to a number
of states that did not follow the
constitutional requirement for selecting
electors madam speaker this is something
that is clear that our founding fathers
debated about as a fundamental
decision of how we choose our president
there was a lot of back and forth if
anyone reads
the founding documents of our country
about
the different versions they went through
to ultimately come up with a process
where each state has elections each
state has a process
for selecting their electors and sending
them to washington
and madam speaker in a number of those
states
that constitutional process was not
followed and that's why we're here to
object if you look
at what the requirement says nowhere
in article 2 section 1 does it give the
secretary
of state of a state that ability nowhere
does it give the governor that ability
nowhere does it give
a court that ability it exclusively
gives that ability
to the legislatures and in fact in most
states that's the process that was
followed
but for those states that this wasn't
followed
unfortunately this is not new we've seen
over and over again more states where
the democrat party has gone in and
selectively gone around
this process that has to end madam
speaker
we have to follow the constitutional
process
now there might be reasons why some
people don't like the process
laid out by a legislative body madam
speaker i served on one of those
legislative bodies when i was in the
state
legislature for 12 years i served on the
house and governmental affairs committee
where we wrote the laws
for our states elections and i can tell
you
when we had to make changes those were
extensively negotiated
we would have people on both sides come
republicans and democrats madam speaker
would get together to work through those
changes any minute change
to how a precinct would function
to how a change would be made in the
time of an election
signature requirements all the many
things that involve
a clerk carrying out the duties in each
parish in our case
you would see people come and give
testimony
madam speaker both sides could come
clerks of court were there
in the hearing rooms it was an open
process by the way
not behind closed doors in a
smoke-filled room
where somebody might want to bully a
secretary of state to get
a different version that might benefit
them or their party or their candidate
that's not what our founding father said
is the process
maybe it's how some people wanted to
carry it out but they laid out that
process
and so when we would have to make those
changes they were in public view
they were heavily debated and then
ultimately
those laws were changed in advance of
the election so
everybody knew where the rules were
people on both sides
knew how to play the rules before not
getting somewhere in the process and
saying well you don't think it's going
to benefit you
so you try to go around the constitution
that's not how our system works it's
gotten out of hand
and so president trump has called this
out
and president trump has stood up to it
so many of us have stood up to it
and in fact over a hundred of my
colleagues madam speaker asked the
supreme court
to address this problem just a few weeks
ago
and unfortunately the court chose to
punt
they didn't answer it one way or the
other they didn't want to get in the
middle of this discussion
we don't have that luxury today
we have to discuss this we have to fix
this
in fact on our first full day of this
congress
many of us brought legislation onto the
house floor
to start fixing the problems with our
elections to restore
integrity to the election process which
has been lost by so many
millions of americans and we had a vote
every single republican voted to reform
the process
every single democrat voted against it
they don't want to fix this problem
but the constitution is our guide
and it's time we start following the
constitution it's time we get back
to what our founding father said is the
process for selecting electors that's
the legislatures
in public view not behind closed doors
not smoke-filled rooms
not bullying somebody that might give
you a better ruling let's get back to
rule
of law and follow the constitution madam
speaker
and i yield back the balance of my time
damage time has expired
for what purpose does the jacket woman
[Applause]
what purpose does the gentlewoman from
california seek recognition to strike
the last word
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for madam speakers
madam speaker this day marks a
crossroads for american democracy
those who objected the counting of the
electoral college votes
which reflect the votes of the american
people wants to set want to substitute
their preferences for the voters choice
that's not what our constitution
requires and it's at odds with the
american democratic republic
if congress selects the next president
instead of american voters
will have no need for an electoral
college in fact we'd have no need for
presidential elections at all
we'd be moving from a government elected
by the people
to a government selected by those
already governing
that's not america in the united states
we abide
by the choices of the people not an
elite few
the framers of our constitution
considered whether to have congress
select the president
and specifically rejected it instead
they wrote article two
and the twelfth amendment article 2
creates the electoral college
where each state appoints electors laws
of all 50 states and d.c
require electors to vote for the winner
of the state's popular election
each state provides for the orderly
conduct of elections
including lawful challenges recounts and
the like
the 12th amendment is what brings us to
today it says the electors meet in their
states that happened december 14th
the amendment says the electors shall
cast their votes sign and certify them
transmit them to a seal that's been done
the sealed envelopes containing the
signed certified ballots from each
state's electors
reflecting the votes of the people were
in those mahogany boxes
the 12th amendment directs the president
as the vice president is the president
of senate to do only this
open the sealed envelopes and then the
vote shall be counted simple
it doesn't say countered in a manner
that some members of congress
the vice president might prefer no the
votes are simply to be counted as
certified and transmitted by the states
during reconstruction after the civil
war more than one
slate of electors were appointed by
states
dueling lists were sent and protracted
processes were undertaken in
presidential elections
and as a result to make an orderly
process
congress enacted the electoral count act
of 1887.
this law governs our proceedings today
the act provides
dispute resolution mechanisms under the
eca
if a governor certifies a slate of
electors and there are no competing
slaves from that state
the governor's certified slate must be
counted today every single slate of
electors won by joe
biden or one by donald trump got their
governor's certification
not a single state submitted a competing
slate there's no dispute to resolve
the 2020 election was the most secure
election conducted in modern history
challenge were resolved by lawful
recounts and audits
the result vice president biden won the
2020 election
more than 60 lawsuits were filed and
contesting elements of the election
process
none of these lawsuits prevailed why as
even president trump's
own judicial appointees ruled there was
no evidence of any wrongdoing
that would change the outcome the people
spoke it was not a close election
the margin of victory for biden in 2020
was larger than trump's margin
in 2016. in fact the biden victory
is one of the most decisive in modern
times exceeding the margin enjoyed by
reagan when he defeated
carter in 1980
congress has gathered in joint session
to count electable votes
every four years since 1789.
i understand the disappointment people
feel when their candidate for president
loses
i felt the same several times in my
voting life when that happens
it's not an invitation to upend the
constitution
and the laws of the united states it's
an invitation to work with the new
president for the good of the country
and to wait for the next election in
four years if you're dissatisfied
in that spirit i urge my colleagues to
uphold
the american democracy and reject the
objection
and i yield back the balance of my time
[Applause]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
ohio seek recognition
speaker i rise to support the objection
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for five minutes
madam speaker americans instinctively
know there was something wrong with this
election
during the campaign vice president biden
would do an event you get 50 people at
the event president trump
at just one rally gets 50 000 people
president trump increases vote with
african-americans increases vote with
hispanic americans won 19 of 20
bellwether counties
won ohio by eight iowa by eight and
florida by three got 11 million more
votes than he did in 2016
and house republicans won 27 of 27
toss-up races
but somehow the guy who never left his
house
wins the election 80 million americans
80 million of our fellow
citizens republicans and democrats have
doubts about this election
and 60 million people 60 million
americans think it was stolen
but democrats say no problem no worries
everything's fine we asked for an
investigation
we asked chairman nadler chairwoman
maloney for an investigation they said
no
wouldn't want to investigate something
that half the electorate has doubts
about
it's just the presidency of the united
states
why why not one single investigation why
not even
one single hearing over the last nine
weeks in the united states house of
representatives why
because all the democrats care about is
making sure president trump isn't
president
for four and a half years that's all
they've cared about
july 31st 2016 before he was elected the
first time
jim comey's fbi takes out the insurance
policy
opens an investigation on the president
based on nothing may 17 2017 bob mueller
named special counsel
two years they investigate the russia
hoax 19 lawyers
40 agents and 40 million dollars of
taxpayer money for nothing
december 18 2019
democrat house members vote to impeach
president trump
based on an anonymous whistleblower with
no firsthand knowledge
who was biased against the president and
who worked
for joe biden but none of that worked
as hard as they tried none of that
worked they threw everything they had
at him so what'd they do next
they changed the rules they changed the
election law
and they did it in an unconstitutional
fashion and that's what we're going to
show
over the next several hours of debate
the constitution is clear
as as whip scalise just said state
legislatures and only state legislatures
set election law
in arizona the law says voter
registration ends on october 5th
democrats said we don't care what the
law says they went to a court
got an obama appointed judge to extend
it 18 days
no debate as steve talked about no
debate no discussion he just did it
pennsylvania same thing pennsylvania law
says mail and ballots have to be in by 8
pm election day
democrat supreme court said nope we're
going to extend it
election day doesn't end on tuesday now
they took it to friday
extended the election three days not the
legislature
partisan supreme court pennsylvania law
says mail-in ballots require signature
verification
democrat secretary of state said nope
i'm going to decide by myself that it
doesn't for 2.6
million ballots pennsylvania law says
mail-in
ballots can't be processed until
election day
some counties said no and you can
imagine which counties they were
democrat ron county said no and allowed
ballots
to be cured and fixed before election
day
they did an in run around the
constitution
in every state that republicans will
object to today
every single one it was a pattern it was
their template
they did it in arizona they did it in
georgia they did it in michigan they did
it in pennsylvania they did it nevada
they did it in wisconsin
and yet some of our members some members
say
don't worry about it we shouldn't do
anything
just let it go it was just six states
who violated the constitution
what if it's 10 states next time what if
it's 15
what if in 2024 2028 it's 26 states what
if it's half the states
do an end run amount the constitution
clearly spells out
we we are the final check and balance
the authority rests with us the united
states congress
the body closest to the american people
right where the founders wanted it
we should do our duty we should object
to and
and and vote for this objection to the
arizona
electors madam chair i yield back
thank you
purpose does the gentleman from
california
seek recognition madam speaker i rise in
opposition to the objection
the gentleman is recognized with that
objection for five minutes
madam speaker a little more than two
months ago america performed an
extraordinary feat
under some of the most trying
circumstances in our history our fellow
citizens conducted
a free and fair election vindicating our
founders belief once again that we were
capable of self-government
and a peaceful transition of power on
november 3rd the american people chose
joe biden to be their next president
by an enormous margin the successful
conduct of that election among the most
secure in american history
was not an accident it was the result of
the dedicated work of thousands of
volunteers canvassers poll workers
electors and state and local election
officials
when the conduct of any state election
was challenged
the courts through judges appointed by
democrats and those appointed by
republicans
heard unsubstantiated claims of fraud
found they had no merit and said so
but most important the american people
persevered
in the midst of the worst pandemic in a
century america had one of the most
impressive elections in a century
with historic voter turnout our fellow
citizens
did their civic duty the question we
face
today is will we do ours
that we are here with a substantial
number of our members seeking to
overturn an election is remarkable
tragic and all too predictable
ford is the natural result of a
locomotive set in motion months ago with
a myth
for weeks and weeks before during and
after our election a dangerous falsehood
was propagated
that our election would be marred by
massive fraud
never mind it was the same election
which brought the very men and women to
this chamber
who would challenge its results what
value has consistency
when measured against ambition a former
senator from georgia
remarking on a contested election over a
century ago
said that able-men learned men
distinguished men great men in the eyes
of the nation
seemed intent only on accomplishing a
party triumph
without regard to the consequences to
the country
that is human nature that is he said
unfortunately party nature
was he right we stand in a house
which was once the place of giants have
we become
so small does our oath to uphold the
constitution
taken just days ago mean so
very little i think not
i believe to quote our dear departed
friend elijah cummings that we
are better than that i think elijah
would be proud that the debate here
today is not between democrats and
republicans
and that some republicans including the
republican leader of the senate
remain devoted to the principle that we
are a nation of laws
not individuals let alone a single
individual it may seem unfair
to the new members who have only just
taken the oath for the first time
that they should be so soon tested with
one of the most consequential votes
they may cast no matter how long they
serve but it is so
and none of us can shrink from that
responsibility
nor can we console ourselves with the
intoxicating fiction
that we can break that oath without
consequence
because doing so will not succeed in
overturning the election
an oath is no less broken
when the breaking fails to achieve its
end
we must be mindful that any who seek to
overturn an election will do
injury to our constitution whatever the
result
for just as the propagation of that
dangerous myth about this election made
this moment inevitable our actions today
will put another train in motion
this election will not be overturned but
what about the next
or the one after that what shall we say
when our democratic legacy is no more
substantial than the
air except that we brought trouble to
our own house
and inherited the wind this isn't the
first time
we've had a contentious election and it
won't be the last
in 1800 john adams lost the closely
contested election to thomas jefferson
in the first peaceful transition of
power from one party to another in our
history
adams was hardly pleased with the result
choosing to skip the inaugural
activities
but he did what leaders are required to
do
in a democratic government when they
lose
he went home
he went home jefferson
that's my time expired ministry 10
seconds would later refer to his victory
as the revolution of 1800 but marveled
that the revolution had occurred
by the rational and peaceful instruments
of reform the suffrage of the people
it has never been our place
to return an election and if we hope to
remain a democracy it never will be
arizona
for what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition
i right to support the objection without
objection the gentleman is recognized
for five minutes
thank you madam speaker i joined the
objection to counting votes
of electors from my home state of
arizona as well as georgia pennsylvania
wisconsin
michigan and nevada because election
integrity is the heart of our american
constitutional republic
in a representative form of government
we must be able to trust
that our elections accurately represent
the will of the american voter
this is the appropriate forum
anticipated and provided for by our
founders to debate whether this election
complied
with the constitution that we've all
sworn to protect every particular of the
constitution is to be protected
including article 2
section 1. the debate as to the
legitimacy of the 2020 presidential
election
has been suppressed by the left and is
propagandist in the media
until today state legislatures are
required to determine the manner
in which electors are chosen arizona
names its electors on the general
election ballot and identifies what
candidate those electors
are required to vote for should that
candidate obtain the majority of votes
in the general election
as part of the matter for determining
electors arizona also establishes
deadlines for voter registration
the deadline has been in place for 30
years this year the voter registration
deadline was october 5th
early voting commenced two days later
five days before the deadline
a group filed a lawsuit demanding that
arizona election officials not enforce
the deadline
the federal district court decided that
since other states have a deadline later
than arizona's
and some even allow for registration
when voting that arizona's new deadline
would be a time
he chose not the legislators timeline
the appellate court effectively
overturned the lower court ruling and
noted that the arizona deadline
established by the state legislature
was sound and appropriate and complied
with the constitution
but the appellate court merely shortened
the
extension the bypassing of the deadline
to 10 days
the appellate court without legal
justification also decided that everyone
who registered
after the legal deadline but before the
deadline created by judicial fiat
could still vote note that the arizona
legislature was no longer in control of
determining the manner of appointing
presidential electors because the court
had set a new deadline
even though the appellate court found
the legislature's deadline was
constitutionally sound
during that window more than 32 thousand
voters
registered in maricopa county alone here
are copies of those voter registration
records
in going around the deadline set by the
legislature the court
ignored the arizona legislative
legislature's obligation
and right to direct the manner for
choosing presidential electors
as set forth in article two section one
as a consequence of that judicial
usurpation
more than 32 000 people were allowed to
unlawfully cast
ballots in arizona's presidential
election in 2020
the arizona legislature seeks an
independent audit of the election
the governor refuses now to call them
into a special session
the maricopa county board of supervisors
has refused to comply
with legislative subpoenas in arizona
the people who control the evidence
related to the election have done
everything possible
to prevent an independent audit directed
by the legislature
arizonans have used the limited amount
of records available to investigate
investigate the 2020 presidential
election of a limited sample of 1 000
addresses of voters
they found 539 voters did not live at
the addresses on the voter rolls
here is a stack of a thousand
declaration of affidavits
supporting that i object to the continue
counting the votes of arizona electors
because the federal courts
went around the legislatively
constructed mechanism for choosing
arizona's presidential electors
allowing tens of thousands of voters to
unlawfully cast votes
the court usurped a key component of the
arizona legislature's manner
of selecting presidential electors thus
violating article 2 section 1.
the legislature is being obstructed in
its efforts and
what little evidence we have our little
information we have has produced this
kind of
evidence which indicates a significant
problem with the integrity of the
presidential election
madam speaker i ask that my comments my
written comments together with the voter
registration records that reflect the
thirty two thousand registrations
permitted to in contravention of state
law letters and resolutions from arizona
legislators
pertaining to the count of votes from
electors along with approximately 1 000
affidavits and declarations
pertaining to potential voter fraud in
arizona in the 2020 presidential
election
and the statement of congressman randy
weber of texas be made a part of the
record
thank the gentleman for what purpose
does the gentleman from maryland seek
recognition
mr speaker i rise in opposition to the
objection
the gentleman is recognized without
objection for five minutes
madam speaker i want to thank you first
and and all my dear beloved colleagues
for your love and tenderness which my
family and i
will never forget
[Applause]
hmm
[Applause]
thank you again abraham lincoln
whose name is a comfort to us all
said we've got the best government the
world
ever knew it's best because the first
three words of the constitution
tell us who governs here
we the people watch this proceeding
today
and tell the world with pride as lincoln
did
about the brilliant meaning and promise
of our country
our government belongs to the people
as president ford said here the people
rule
today we are in the people's house to
complete the people's process
for choosing the people's president
we assemble and join session for a
solemn purpose that we've all sworn a
sacred oath
to faithfully discharge the 12th
amendment obligates each and every one
of us
to count the electoral votes to
recognize the will of the people in the
2020
presidential election we are not here
madam speaker to vote for the candidate
we want
we are here to recognize the candidate
the people actually voted for in the
states
madam speaker the 2020
election is over and the people
have spoken
joe biden received more than 80 million
votes seven million more
than president trump a number larger
than any other president
has received in u.s history this
sweeping popular victory
translated into an electoral college
victory
of 306 to 232 a margin which president
trump
pronounced a landslide when he won those
by those exact same numbers in 2016.
so now we count the electoral votes that
were just delivered to us
in the beautiful mahogany cases brought
by those hard-working senate pages
these mahogany cases contain
only the 538 electoral votes that were
sent in by the states not
the 159 million ballots that were cast
by our constituents those were counted
two months ago
by hundreds of thousands of election
officials and poll workers
across america who risked their health
and even their lives
in the time of covid to deliver what our
department of homeland security called
the most secure election in american
history
many of these officials have endured
threats of retribution
violence and even death just for doing
their jobs
just as the popular vote was for biden
so was the electoral vote on december
15th
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
recognized it
the electoral colleges spoken senator
mcconnell said from the senate floor
today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden
yet we have seen escalating attacks on
our election
with unfounded claims of fraud and
corruption more than 60 lawsuits have
been brought to date
seeking to overturn the results they
have failed repeatedly and they have
failed spectacularly
every objection we hear today maligning
our states and their officials both
republican and democrat
has been litigated adjudicated and
obliterated
in both federal and state court the
president has not just had his day in
court my friends
he has had more than two months in court
looking for a judge to embrace these
arguments
in more than 50 cases madam speaker at
least 88 different judges including many
appointed by the president himself have
meticulously rejected
the president's claims of fraud and
corruption take georgia u.s district
judge stephen grimberg
named to the bench by president trump
this year he last year he rejected
trump's prayer
to block certification of biden's
victory in georgia
saying it has no basis in fact
or law take u.s district judge brett
ludwig
another trump nominee who took the bench
in september he dismissed a lawsuit
seeking to overturn the results in
wisconsin call it an extraordinary
a sitting president who did not prevail
in his bid for reelection
has asked for federal court help and
setting aside the popular vote
based on issues he plainly could have
raised before the vote occurred
he wrote this court has allowed
plaintiff the chance to make his case
and he has lost on the merits
trump has asked for the rule of law to
be followed judge ludwig observed
and he said definitively it has been
i've been a constitutional law professor
for 30 years and if i were to test my
students on these decisions
it would be the easiest test in the
world because the plaintiffs have lost
nearly
every case and every issue in the most
sweeping terms
that's all they would have to remember
there is no basis in factor law
to justify the unprecedented relief that
is being requested
of nullifying these elections we are
here to count the votes
let us do our job
thank you for what purpose does a
gentlewoman from colorado seek
recognition
i rise to support the objection uh the
gentlewoman is recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam speaker and to ease
everyone's nerve i want you to all know
that i am not here
to challenge anyone to a jewel like
alexander hamilton
or aaron burr madam speaker my primary
objection to the counting of the
electoral votes
of the state of arizona is based on the
constitution and the direction of state
legislatures
through state law as spelled out in the
following two clauses article 2 section
1
clause 2 states in part and i quote each
state shall appoint in such manner
as the legislature thereof may direct a
number of electors
and the election clause of the
constitution provides state
legislatures with explicit authority to
prescribe and i quote
the times places and manners of holding
elections
end quote for more than three decades
arizona law
set by the state legislature has
required that voter registration in no
later
than 29 days before an election this is
clear
it is law unless amended by the state
legislature
this is the way it needs to be carried
out in arizona the deadline for voter
registration for the 2020 presidential
election
was october 5 2020 using covid
as a reasoning democrats filled a loss
filed a lawsuit
to extend this deadline by 18 days
and an injunction was made by an obama
appointed judge preventing the
arizona secretary of state from
enforcing the constitutional deadline
set by the state legislature as a result
of this frivolous
partisan lawsuit 10 extra days
were added via judicial fiat
to allow voter registration these 10
days were added after
voting had already begun this is
completely indefensible
you cannot change the rules of an
election while it is underway and expect
the american people to trust it
now in this 10-day period at least
30 000 new voters registered to vote in
arizona
all of these votes are unconstitutional
it does not matter
if they voted for president trump or if
they voted for vice president
biden they did not register in time for
the election
the law states october 5th either we
have laws
or we do not if we allow state election
laws
as set forth by the state legislature to
be ignored and manipulated
on the whims
[Music]
the house will be in order
if we allow state election laws as set
forth by state legislatures to be
ignored and manipulated on the whims of
partisan lawsuits
unelected bureaucrats unlawful
procedures and arbitrary rules
then our constitutional republic will
cease to
exist the oath that i took this past
sunday to defend
and support the constitution makes it
necessary
for me to object to this travesty
otherwise the laws passed by the
legislative
branch merely become suggestions to be
accepted
rejected or manipulated by those who did
not
pass them madam speaker i have
constituents outside this building right
now i promised my voters to be
their voice in this branch of government
which i now serve
it is my separate but equal obligation
to weigh in on this election
and object are we not a government of
buying for the people
they know that this election is not
right and it's their representative i am
sent here to rep resent them i will not
allow the people to be ignored madam
speaker it is my duty under the u.s
constitution to object
to the counting of the electoral votes
of the state of arizona
the members who stand here today and
accept the results
of this concentrated coordinated
partisan effort
by democrats where every fraudulent vote
cancels out the vote of an honest
america has sided with the extremists
left the united states congress needs to
make an informed decision and that
starts with this
objection i yield the balance of my time
to the gentleman from florida mr bryant
madam speaker i rise as well to support
the objection
and i rise with a simple question
can the chair honestly tell americans
that with pending supreme court
legislation
or subpending supreme court case over
legal observers
not being allowed to observe and inspect
signatures
that the laws and constitution of that
state
were not violated to change voting
outcomes madam speaker i will wait for a
response
25 seconds remaining i will repeat my
question can you honestly tell americans
that with pending supreme court case
over legal observers not being able to
observe and inspect
signatures that the laws and
constitution of arizona
did not be violated to change voting
outcomes and i will wait for a response
okay gentleman's time has expired
what purpose does the gentleman from
colorado seek recognition
madam speaker i rise in opposition to
the objection
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for five minutes
madam speaker today is an important day
in 1862 during the depths of the civil
war
president lincoln submitted his annual
message
to congress to this body and in it he
wrote the following
fellow citizens we cannot escape history
we of this congress and this
administration
will be remembered in spite of ourselves
the fiery trial through which we pass
will light us down in honor
or dishonor to the latest generation we
shall nobly
save or meanly lose
the last best hope of earth
we gather today madam speaker to ensure
the survival of our grand american
experiment
the greatest democracy this world has
ever known and there are millions
of people watching today's proceedings
the eyes of the world
are on us now my colleagues wondering
if we will keep the faith wondering
if our constitutional republic
will hold will we adhere
to our constitution that solemn
visionary document that has guided us
so well for so long and enabled the
peaceful transfer of power
for the last 230 years
will we continue to be a country
premised
on the consent of the government a
congress
that respects the will of the people and
a republic
that will endure those are the questions
before us
today madam speaker with respect to my
new colleague from colorado the question
is not
whether joe biden was elected the 46th
president of the united states
he clearly was the people of arizona
like so much of the country spoke
clearly
and resoundingly they voted in record
numbers and over 81 million americans
selected joe biden as the next
president now today we hear from some
in this chamber not all but some of my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle
vague claims of fraud no substance
no evidence no facts
no explanation for why over 88 judges
across this land have rejected the very
same claims madam speaker the bottom
line is this
as my colleague representative raskin so
eloquently put it
the people have spoken and that is why
on december 14th
the electoral college met to certify the
election of a duly elected president
just
as they've done for centuries during
terrible world wars
recessions depressions plagues and
pandemics
they met they met their duty
and they once again rose to the occasion
and certified the election and the
question now
is will we do ours now i know there are
many
textualists among us many of my
colleagues who would understand that the
constitution
must guide our work today and the
constitution
is crystal clear our duty today is a
narrow one
article two section 1 clause
3 reads the president of the senate
shall in the presence of the senate and
the house
open all the certificates and the votes
shall then be counted
the person having the greatest number of
votes shall be
the president that's it
period our job is not to replace
the judgment made by the american people
with our own
and yet that is precisely what so many
of my house and senate republican
colleagues
ask this body to do to substitute
their judgment for the expressed will
of the american people in america we
don't do that
in the united states we accept the
results of free
and fair elections we don't ignore the
will of the voters madam speaker
and attempt to install a preferred
candidate into our power into power that
doesn't happen here
i will close with this our duty our task
is a very simple one to honor the voice
of the people
to honor our constitution to count
the votes certify this election
and begin to heal this great country of
ours
i pray each of us may find the courage
to do so with that i yield back
my pajamas
for what purpose does the gentleman from
louisiana seek recognition
madam speaker i rise in support of the
objection the gentleman is recognized
for five minutes madam speaker we have a
solemn responsibility today
we must vote to sustain objections to
states of electors
submitted by states that we genuinely
believe clearly violated the
constitution
and the presidential election of 2020.
this is the threshold legal question
before us
and it's an issue before us for the
state of arizona
we got to repeat this for emphasis
because a lot of people seem to be
confused
because judges and not the state
legislature changed the rules of the
election
arizona clearly violated the plain
language of article 2 section 1 of the
constitution
in its selection of presidential
electors the framers of our constitution
recognized that elections were
susceptible to corruption we all know
that so how did they fix it
how did they provide for that they
created the electoral college as a
safeguard
and they expressly empowered state
legislatures to ensure the integrity of
our unique election system
only the state legislatures because
they're a full body of representatives
and not rogue officials
were given the authority to direct the
manner of appointing presidential
electors because it was so important
the supreme court has acknowledged this
over and over they previously affirmed
in article 2 section 1 clause 2 quote
the appointment of these electors is
thus placed
absolutely and wholly with the
legislatures of the several states
that authority can never be taken away
or abdicated
the arizona legislature did enact
detailed rules and procedures
that that state was determined uh and
was supposed to follow to choose its
electors but in
the months preceding the 2020 election
as we've heard and by the way a thousand
pages of evidence
have just been submitted on the facts on
this those well-established rules and
procedures were deliberately changed
they weren't changed by the legislature
friends they were changed
by judges and those actions taken by the
judiciary were not limited to mere
interpretations of existing law no they
they were substantive wholesale changes
to those statutes
that's a usurpation of the authority
that the legislature had that usurpation
was repeated across the country this
year
it it's um it's the primary reason it's
one of the reasons why the election of
2020 became riddled with an
unprecedented number of serious
allegations of fraud and irregularities
all over the country
national polls has been said indicate
that a huge percentage of americans
now have serious doubts about not just
the outcome of this presidential contest
but also the future reliability of our
election system itself
since we're convinced since we are
convinced
that the election laws in arizona and
some other key states were changed in
this unconstitutional manner
we have a responsibility today the
slates of electors produced under those
modified laws
are thus unconstitutional they are quote
not
regularly given or lawfully certified as
required by the federal
uh the electoral account act and uh
they're invalid on their face that's
just
the conclusion that you have to reach
given these inescapable facts we believe
we have no choice today but to vote to
sustain objections
to those slates of electors mr raskin
and others today have cited the 12th
amendment
and they they cite article 2 section 1
clause 3. remember that clause 3
and they've asserted that congress has
only one narrow role today we're just
supposed to count the electoral votes
that have been submitted
but those advocates have overlooked a
critical first principle the
their assertion is is only true so long
as
congress first is convinced that the
electoral votes that are produced by a
process
that that violated the constitution uh
is there they we got to get through
clause
two of article two section one before we
get to clause three is the point
look in our unique system congress is
positioned as the last bulwark in a
in a presidential election to ensure the
constitution has been followed
indeed in just two decades just two
decades ago the supreme court spoke to
this they plainly acknowledged
this important deliberative role of
congress it was the famous bush before
litigation that everybody
remembers from 2000 in a per curious
opinion meaning all nine justices it was
unanimous
they noted strict adherence to the
provisions that the electoral account
act
may quit quote create a safe harbor for
a state
insofar as congressional consideration
of its electoral votes is concerned
however they said unanimously the court
said
since title three section five contains
a principle of federal law that would
assure finality of the state's
determination if they followed all the
prescriptions there
if a legislature uh the world
legislature is trying to is
is uh attempted to be changed by a state
court that is a problem
that they said congress might deem to be
a change in the law that's precisely
why we're here right now go read bush v
gore and you'll see this
chief justice william rehnquist and
scalia and thomas joined in
a concurring opinion eight days later
and they reiterated this point
a significant departure from the
legislature scheme for appointing
presidential electors
presents a federal question it's a big
problem for us
and it's one we cannot get around that's
why we're here i urge my colleagues
today to look at the facts
to follow the law and follow our
congressional oath we're supposed to
support and defend the constitution
that's what we do here today i urge
everyone to do the right thing and i
yield back
the woman's time has expired
[Applause]
for what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona the dean of the arizona
delegation seek recognition thank you
madam speaker i
i rise in opposition uh to the objection
the gentleman is recognized for five
minutes
thank you madam speaker um this exercise
of futility that
congress is undertaking is at the behest
of republican members of congress
the effort to overturn the presidential
election
and grant donald trump four more years
is uh
is is the motivation behind it and to
continue
a baseless conspiracy-fueled
uh threat to our democracy uh
makes no sense because there is no
viable constitutional
or legal path to overturn the election
that will make vice president biden and
senator harris president vice president
of the united states after january 20th
one certain outcome of this whole
process is the weakening
of our democracy and the threatening of
our democracy
beginning with arizona congress is being
asked
to chase down a rabbit hole baseless
discredited and judicially discarded
fringe conspiracy theories
but for the record let's talk a little
bit about arizona
arizona and state and local
officials did an unbelievable job
to ensure that the 220 elections ran
smoothly
mr hickman the republican chairman of
the maricopa
county party the largest county in the
state of arizona said
no matter how you voted this election
was administered with integrity
transparency and in accordance with
state laws
arizona showed up to the polls in record
numbers more than 3.4 million people
voted
increases in every county and a 65
percent
of all eligible voters in arizona voted
in the 2020 election
arizona's cast their ballots up and down
for republicans and democrats
and 11 electoral votes were
were granted to joe biden and kamala
harris
based on their victory in arizona
that's the story voted arizona voted in
hundreds of races this year
and in addition to the presidency these
races include
nine members of the state's
congressional delegation that are with
you
four of them my republican colleagues
these members have already been seated
in the 117th congress
they do not question the accuracy of
arizona's 220 elections
to select a congressional delegation yet
my four republican colleagues uh
question
the presidential election our colleagues
may say
they are only questions or only asking
questions
and seeking to reassure voters but let
us be clear
these questions have been answered by
the voters and by the courts
rather than accepting the answers and
the results of the election
they are fanning the flames of unfounded
suspicion and once again
creating a threat a very real and
dangerous threat to our democracy
again our friends do not question the
outcomes of their own elections
that is because they have no reason to
just as they have no
legitimate reason to question the
results of the presidential
election in arizona i
asked my colleagues to reject this
objection
to respect the will of the voters in the
state of arizona and throughout this
country and to fundamentally
add some preservation to our democracy
for many future damage that this effort
that we are undertaking in this house
today
and in the senate today uh does not
further damage our democracy now yield
back
[Applause]
what purpose does the gentleman from
arizona seek recognition madam speaker i
rise in support of my
objection the gentleman is recognized
for five minutes
madam speaker i filed my petition
a challenge on the slate of that
electors from the state of arizona
that was actually put forward by
governor ducey of arizona
my ask to you the speaker to the vice
president
is simple do not count these electors
until and unless
the secretary of state allows a forensic
audit
of the election request she has denied
repeatedly
we have been told over and over that
even though this was public
a public election using public money on
public machines utilizing public
employees
the public today has no ability to
simply double check the veracity
of these results if the presidential
election was a football game
we would get a slow motion review from
multiple angles
and a correction of a controversial
decision
but not so we are told by our secretary
of state for the presidential election
no no review for you no access to the
dominion voting machines with a
documented history of enabling fraud
through its now discredited
adjudication system a system that
literally allows
one person to change tens of thousands
of votes in a mere
minutes in the only audit done in
arizona
a court found three percent error rate
against
president trump vice president biden's
margin of error
was one-tenth of that at .03 percent
by the way a three percent error rate at
minimum is 90
000 ballots after finding the three
percent error rate
the court stopped the audit and refused
to go further
in arizona as my attachments made clear
mail-in ballots were
altered on the first day of counting as
shown in data graphs we
provide and it's concluded by data
analysts
over four hundred thousand mail-in
ballots were altered switched from
president trump to
vice president biden are completely
erased from president trump's totals
the proof is in accounting curves the
curves that cannot occur except with
odds so rare and unlikely
that winning the mega millions lottery
is more probable
madam mr speaker can i have order in the
chamber
the house will be in order
the house will be in order okay
okay
the house will be in order
else will be in order
members will take their seats the house
will be in order
okay
we can resume
[Music]
wow
oh
[Music]
without objection the chair declares the
house in recess pursuant to clause 12b
of rule
are you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
safe trips
[Music]
hey chris
okay okay we'll do
okay thank you
understood okay sounds good bye
hey guys sorry i'm going to have to
switch over we're on wusa9 digital right
now
so switch over to our facebook page and
our website
or our free wusa9 app we're going to
pick up coverage there
okay we're still up on digital i got a
live shot for right now
look at that abc oh that's fake
okay what i'm starting to see now people
with their
gas masks on potentially in anticipation
of
any sort of use of an irritant by
capitol police
we have not seen any of evidence of that
as of yet
[Music]
you know what i'm not seeing jesse i'm
not seeing where those capitol police
officers went after
they got here that was mpv
[Music]
okay
[Music]
if you guys are just tuning into this we
are on the back side of the capitol
building
protesters have overtaken capitol police
and breached the stairs of the back
capital the gates are
down that we're holding them back
peacefully throughout the day
it started off with one or two
protesters
as the gentleman said in general people
have been very upset about the results
of the election and they feel that
by being here they will show the will of
the people
and that they want president trump to be
confirmed as
the next president again as our election
was stolen
[Music]
an interesting juxtaposition is
literally right behind our camera
is a prayer circle where they have been
praying since around nine
o'clock this morning even while the
protesters breached the fence and
stormed the steps the
prayer warriors over on my right hand
side have been praying
chanting mercy if you can hear them
jesse can you show the prayer
circle
earlier this morning cindy jacobs was
out here leading the group
in prayer asking for some sort of
explicit evidence
that would confirm that the election was
stolen
it has been debated and refuted multiple
times that this
has been a clean election and right
behind these doors
a joint commission of the senate and the
house are voting to certify the election
right now which is normally a
ceremonial event i spoke to senator
kaine
about an hour ago who said in 2017
right after the 2016 election the ticket
that he was on
that certification process took about 17
minutes
this one started at one o'clock and it's
unclear when it will end
[Music]
yes
okay there's they're chanting stop the
steal
it's been the chant of the day it's the
the main mission of today's protest
[Music]
up
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get off next to me hurt like hell on my
leg i don't know if i got marks on my
leg or not but
i don't want to get down your eyes are a
little hard but did you feel anything
uh this is pepper spray that was yeah
that was a huge flash yeah big
big uh what do you call a concussion
when it when it goes off
it says flash vanguard so i guess it's a
flash grenade
do you mind if i hold on to this i was
going to keep it as a souvenir
yeah i mean i got the marks
i earned it wow
[Music]
is that picture from right after it
happened what is that uh well i got i
got
video and [ __ ] let's see
[Music]
wow that was right up there do you mind
sending those to me
no which here oh who are you nine usa
yeah
yeah if we get out of this you can air
drop them to me uh
i'm not i'm not real versatile i can i
can tell you i can show you how to do it
okay here let's cancel that out
let's go to your photos okay and then
recents select
[Music]
some of that's video too i videoed a
bunch okay and then
was this one oh this was on the stairs
this is on the stairs this is where
everybody's pushing
jumping up and down on okay and then
we'll hit this button right here
okay and then and then airdrop let me
oh no people fail that's because here
we'll do this um
preparing icloud link as long as you
know what you're doing
[Music]
there we go that means go right to your
phone it should
okay there's video there too it's not
coming
except through we go hold on it'll be i
think it's just taking a second to come
through
some close-up video right in the middle
of the crowd thank you what's your name
i'm dan stover dan stover thank you dan
where are you from
uh
[Music]
wow
i just can't see it clearly uh there's a
recess now on the count
because there's a lockdown in the
capitol wow okay
so we're hearing that there is a recess
on the count right now
that the capital is being locked down
that the protesters have
breached the actual doors of the capitol
building and are inside
[Music]
stay here
[Music]
and there was uh
[Music]
you said we can't
uh i think torres is on that side the
constitution side
[Music]
what i think i feel like they're just
finding out that there are protesters
[Music]
[Music]
nevermind
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
is
you know
did you go up here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
[Music]
wow
they're waving this outfit
oh
[Music]
is our shot still being used
[Music]
hey buckley are we is that
okay
okay i just wasn't sure if i was going
to talk for digital
i understood
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it is so incredible to me that tear gas
and irritants haven't been deployed
if this would have happened over the
summer
[Music]
[Music]
chris van cleef from cbs is seeing smoke
i think it must be on the other side
[Music]
i'm not seeing it anywhere
you are inside the capitol building
[Music]
okay
can you pretend
yeah do you smell that dusty
it's in the air
[Music]
i'm smelling it
okay we're starting to smell chemical
irritants in the air not sure if it's oc
spray
that they were using over the summer or
pepper spray
it seems to be coming from the right
side of the building but i don't see the
clouds of smoke
that we're hearing reported from other
cbs reporters
what's interesting is you're starting to
see families gather if you can see this
over my left shoulder
and starting to take pictures a
celebratory moment
it seems for people to have breached the
capital fence and to have taken over the
back set of capital stairs
a few moments ago it was clear that the
protesters who decided not to
storm forward found out that protesters
had actually breached
the building where we know that the
count has stopped
and paused momentarily while this
gets under control
[Music]
and now we're smelling more of those
chemical irritants in the air
[Music]
[Music]
yes sir
[Music]
dear bowser she's a city-wide perfume
for dc wednesday january 6
at 6 p.m
i didn't get them
can i read that
[Music]
people in the district are receiving an
alert right now that mayor bowser is
issuing a city-wide curfew
for wednesday january 6th that is today
starting at 6 p.m until thursday january
7th at 6 00 a.m
essential workers including health care
personnel and media are exempt
guys the last time we had a curfew in
place
we think about swan street we think
about what happened to those protesters
that were penned in on that street right
now these protesters seem to be pretty
content staying right here on the
capitol steps
we haven't seen any escalation since
they've charged those steps in fact
[Music]
it's a peaceful demonstration it had
been throughout the day i think this
increase of activity was the only thing
that really just got frustrated
they feel the congress couldn't hear
them all the way back here
i'm not sure that they could hear them
now because they're exiting
hey
those are the sisters from georgia that
we talked to earlier
you know when you listen to people from
around the world
like i hear people in africa and they
say oh this is like
a story and that in this country nobody
wants to do anything about it that's the
frustration
that's what i've been hearing throughout
the day honestly yeah
we know what you know
and this one that i haven't been hearing
as much
that i have
you know hundreds of thousands of
ballots from
[Music]
all of those terms
[Music]
safe sir
do you know where jesse went
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
oh no no no no i'm calling to see if
he's gotten out
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wow we literally were back here
watching them as they break through
but everyone inside is safe that he
knows all
oh yeah
oh thank goodness and right now they're
missing lockdown in the house
okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you nelly thank you
i know you're safe but i hope that your
team stinks to stay safe
yeah girl yes i'll check back in with
you
bye
[Music]
[Music]
i just
[Music]
[Music]
protesters just sang the star-spangled
banner star-spangled banner followed by
a loud round of cheer
i just got confirmation that senators
are on lockdown in the house chamber
right now
there's a small group of them in there
other senators who broke for objections
are in their offices right now we have
not heard any confirmation of
senators that have been harmed we will
keep you updated as we hear more
[Music]
wow
is
before we leave
i'm not hearing from anyone
[Music]
i'm going to charge
exactly
i know that the evening crews are just
coming in now
i guess i'm good to see you i would
imagine
can i borrow this hey there can we get
confirmation if we can power down our
battery how many batteries do we have
[Music]
left
[Music]
i mean we're not good for like the next
four hours i know
i think
darn i left my external heart my
external charger in your car
[Music]
yeah not only that i don't have the core
it's all in the car
[Music]
jesse do you have an iphone cord on you
and i left my external charger in there
yeah i'm at 12 percent
what do we do
i literally don't know what's here
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
hey cover ball is on the roof
i do not want those people coughing on
me
i know
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
ah
[Music]
did you just i thought you just got an
update no no no no oh
i can't i don't have no service up here
i got to get back to everybody
i'm sorry what
i mean i've not heard
thank you
oh
so
chinese
[Music]
you're these people there's
where the hell is the help
people no we were literally just trying
to get confirmation
that that's happening unfortunately we
can't leave this section
i'll bring them to you how about that
say that again i'd bring him to you
please
okay please
are you okay sir you're bleeding on your
hand
oh that was the police beating me
i tried breaking my arm
what is happening
[Music]
we can't let this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can i take a picture of your hand please
take a picture of me
where where
[Music]
[Music]
she was the first one through the window
and when i went to move they stopped
they
shot her they shot a girl in there yeah
i don't know if she's dead what's your
name thomas thomas
where are you from new jersey i came
down here because
not not necessarily because i thought
the whole thing is fraudulent but i
don't know
if someone should look into it and the
fact that they won't even do that
now they're shooting people that i don't
the fact that wrongdoing
that's fraudulent i don't want anything
we need to wait
maybe kill someone i don't know if she's
dead right right i'm gonna i'm reaching
out to my contacts to see if anything
happened inside we can't confirm
obviously we're outside with you guys
that's what all that blood was
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this this needs to be out there because
this this can't represent
me or my children what's your last name
tom brown
how do you feel
thank you make sure that people know
here i'm going to record it as it's on
your phone from my phone so that we have
a record of it just in case come through
uh okay oh i can't see anything can we
do you mind if i hold this
oh i think that i have to start it from
the top of there
do you mind hitting i can't hold it and
hit the button
and then let me
when
it didn't show her i couldn't see her at
the beginning
right oh is your light down on your
phone is that maybe it
might be all the way up yeah it's all
the way up oh wow oh my god
it was we were surrounded by people i'm
sorry
oh look when i do this it's like a
picture of us that's crazy
oh there we go can you hit the can you
hit the camera button on my phone on my
phone
you got it uh-huh and then okay let me
go to video
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you hear me
[Music]
associated press
yeah i interact as little as possible
but give them give them their do
they're out here in the pool with all of
them
um
[Music]
[Music]
yeah man it's gonna be a long night hope
you stay safe
my ears
it is time for us to bring our guns from
our homes and leave our lives in the
house
and put a stop to this freezing export
[ __ ] going on in this building right
here
england thought they could work poured
over us too
and led poison but it's not for them
[Music]
yes
[Music]
okay
stand up
our god the both of our israel the most
high god of the bible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
is
the wickedness that they've done to the
lord's troubled
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
great
tribe called the delaware where's the
mississippi river
where's ohio iowa you wouldn't even have
it
in virginia
i'll get ready for the captain that's
coming
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
america has not been punished
is
because
[Music]
[Music]
you got a question
okay
right
[Music]
is the weaknesses of earth and this is
not just the truth of america
they committed genocide of europe
they couldn't be allowed not everywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
is
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
right
let's see
is
348
is
look like
[Music]
you know why because the ancient
commissions who are in
egypt
[Applause]
okay you're a liar the white image of
christmas
here is the sixth all right you guys
have all been
fooled you've been hoodwinked and making
that christ the so-called white man he
went to egypt
and hit him with the intentions like
that
egypt is also called what egypt is
called
chemist which means black land right
let's see the
good description of so-called jesus
[Music]
we're on your side
oh
i love you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey montgomery county police
are you [ __ ] crazy
[Music]
oh
she wants to talk about the pharaoh i
think she has all the damn information
i think we're not studying
[Music]
egyptians
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
what's your name
[Music]
the same thing
[Music]
sick
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
um
all right
mr
some of us
[Applause]
[Music]
while in my pocket
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
what
come to
is
[Music]
of yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
let's make america great again
[Music]
is
that's why america
all right
[Music]
that's nothing many
thank you
but it doesn't matter because what is
going down
[Music]
long as he's ancient society
[Music]
[Music]
is
by the way
[Applause]
other countries are going to team up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
is there really a question here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that the roman empire
sure
it's kind of south of the supreme court
like give them that general direction
near the uh south capitol hill metro
stop like a couple blocks uh
spot now and then head back to the car
so i can make his life
talk
easier
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
it
oh
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
thank you
[ __ ]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
right here
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you
all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
yes
this is our house
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i mean people are bringing their
children yes to this
me
[Music]
look at this
[Music]
um
oh my god
smith
[Music]
now
what is the inauguration
they're on bikes
that is
oh
like
oh
[Music]
you saw that
so
me
thank you
is
oh
okay
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
much
beautiful
thank you
all right
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
about the same
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up
is
[Music]
who are you guys with
[Music]
[Music]
oh
all right
wow
you have nothing to worry about
will be shut down
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
roll over here
[Music]
oh
i think they just closed them up i think
in the summertime it's like a pool
like water like a fountain they got one
man one there
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
the government
[Music]
[Applause]
and you will never be powered
will never be required never for
anything including
[Music]
worldwide
the trash me
[Music]
thank you
ah
[Music]
eliminated
[Music]
[Applause]
zero
manufacturing
retail all the way back
there will no longer be territorial
limitations
for more of the green country
we will now be free
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
possibly
[Music]
17
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
okay
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is why this government had to get
rid of president trump
is because in a second term he had no
more political
[Music]
united states
[Music]
president trump was never initiated in
any other shadow government
like scotland
uh corporational
[Music]
almost a half century
[Music]
it'll just be like the inauguration all
over again
[Music]
this is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
liberty
have one
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we're gonna walk up a little bit
youtube
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just set off tear gas again
they never answer quick enough i know
they're not listening
[Music]
i'm gonna
[Music]
yeah yeah i've been trying to talk we're
seeing some like tear gas or some kind
of gas being
fired um yeah
and at times i would take our shot live
because
but yeah i can i can do another hit want
to go up there
are you okay
you want to go up there